the mother of my children I'm still with
today like she got pregnant on the first
dat so I could only tell my dad and I
was like Dad like you know I [__] up
he goes we're going to bring a baby into
this family you did not up how do you
know that that baby in there is not
going to be the next short stop for New
York Yanke he goes out to a could be
what are you going to tell your mother
you know your mother she is not going to
like this he goes here's what you do you
introduce her right now today to your
mother this is my girlfriend the love of
my life ma this is the one right here
bang you don't say a [__] word about
that baby you got to get your mother and
Jasmine together they got to be friends
your mother's got to fall in love with
this girl you got to basically
impregnate your mother with the idea of
your girlfriend being impregnated then
this time in 3 months bang we have a
baby it's not going to be so bad she's
going to be like well you know what I
already love Jasmine this is a blessing
if you tell her now you're fed and I did
that and the day I told my mom she was
like I'm so disappointed you guys didn't
tell me earlier what a beautiful
celebration of